Virgin Galactic has successfully sent a
spacecraft to the edge of space the
high-altitude launch is the first
commercial us flight to go beyond the
atmosphere since 2011 and a major
advance for civilian space travel more
than 600 people have bought tickets some
paying a quarter of a million dollars
for the chance of four minutes of
weightlessness beyond the reach of
gravity it's an active grandson founded
Virgin Galactic in 2004 and pleased to
say that he joins us now from the test
site in California's Mojave Desert
welcome to you Richard Branson and
congratulations on today's test flight
and perhaps he can talk us through what
happened well thank you very much
obviously after 14 hard years to take on
Virgin Galactic into space his mementos
historic occasion so what happened this
wonderful spaceship that's behind us and
took off early this morning on this
beautiful day attached to white night
which was a giant plane that we built to
carry her went up to 40,000 feet it then
was dropped away from white night
it fired its rockets and traveled from
nought to 3,000 miles now in eight
seconds piloted by two wonderful
astronauts and soared into space and we
could all see it just you know from
where we were standing going up and up
and up and up and then obviously
disappearing when it went into space and
then the now astronauts which is quite
exciting we were pilots before they had
this incredible experience of being in
space looking at Mexico down there
Canada up there and and had the ride of
a lifetime and and then when they came
back out of space they were traveling at
two-and-a-half thousand miles an hour
back into the Earth's atmosphere and the
the whole spaceship became a John
Chappell cocked whoo slow it up he then
came back into a spaceship formation and
it came back down and landed in front of
the thousands of people who are watching
and I don't think one of us had had a
dry eye
it was just one of the most exhilarating
days of our lives well yes give us a
sense of just how big a moment this is
for you
especially given some of the setbacks
you've had along the way not least that
terrible crash in 2014 and the tragedy
of losing a pilot what did it mean to
you today given that context it meant a
lot for for everybody here there were
800 people Engineers who who have worked
on the spaceship for the last 14 years
wonderful rocket scientists there were
relatives of our test pilots and and yep
rocket science space is tough but to
have finally done something that nobody
else has ever achieved which is to
actually get a commercial spaceship into
space with with people on board yeah
it was just a wonderful wonderful day
and from here you know we'll do a few
more test flights we'll we'll learn
little things from each test flight then
sometime next year I'll get I'll go up
into space and then if every single box
has been ticked
we'll then start putting people up into
space and we have a lot of people who've
said they would love to go to space and
we hope that in the years to come many
people watching this program will become
astronauts on Virgin Galactic and go to
space well yes and as we were saying a
number of people have bought tickets
already so can you give us a you gave us
a sense you want to go into space next
year when do you think those fee paying
passengers if you like and likely to
make the first trips my predictions have
have often been horribly wrong you know
where this has taken 14 years I thought
it would take 7 years so I'm wary about
making predictions but at the moment we
know that that every single box is
ticked that we can safely bring people
up then we'll start contacting our
astronauts and waiting and saying it's
your turn to come and come to New Mexico
where we have a beautiful spaceport and
you'll bring your family
bring your friends come and have the
ride of a lifetime
but you know maybe alright maybe by the
end of next year that should be
happening I think